loki has been a massive success for
marvel studios and disney plus
and the series remains popular with the
die hard mcu fans
the pen ultimate episode journey into
mystery itself a nod to the name of the
1960s comic book in which loki and thor
first appeared
was full of loki easter eggs that had
fans across the internet dissecting
every frame to find
fun little comic book nods this was
particularly true of the vast wasteland
in the void at the end of time which was
full of mcu relics including the dark
aster which is a ship that is associated
with ronin the accuser
yellowjacket's helmet remember him from
ant-man and the remains of a ruined
avengers tower
this is called quang an intriguing
easter egg itself
in the comics quaing enterprises bought
the old avengers building from tony
stark
and it turns out that quang had a direct
relationship with kang
the conqueror the kang mcu rumors have
been floating around for years now
we also met a whole new gaggle of loki
variants in addition to the group which
debuted in the episode iv post-credits
scene
while spotting the thanos copter in the
void was one of the coolest easter eggs
in the entire mcu
because who doesn't love them some
thanos copter there was one
other that joined it at the top of the
ranks episode 5 pulled one of the most
beloved and often poked fun at
characters
straight from the marvel pages and threw
him right into loki
this moment was also doubly special as
it included a special cameo from chris
hemsworth himself
which many viewers of the episode likely
missed just shy of 10 minutes into
episode 5 loki is traveling with his
newfound group of fellow loki's bound
for the shelter of their underground
bunker as the camera pans from above
ground to the hidden layer a major
easter egg hides in the dirt
stuck in a jar that reads t365 is a
miniature thor
who turns out to be the toad of thunder
throg
guess you could say that the jar is some
sort of frog protection fraud protection
frog fraud frog
fraud i think we're on the same page
we're totally on the same page
the tiny but mighty amphibian jumps
around in the jar attempting to reach
mjolnir
while he does this he lets out a few
grunts of frustration
and according to loki director kate
herron these grunts were actually
recorded by chris hemsworth himself
heron clarified that these noises were
not recycled from
any previous films hemsworth actually
did all new voice work
well grunt work just for loki fans were
hoping to get some sort of cameo from
the australian actor in loki and this
was
just the perfect way to do it without
having him steal the spotlight from his
on-screen brother
sorry about that time i turned you into
a frog it was a wonderful joke
as loki writer eric martin revealed
during his live tweet screening of
episode 5
fans could have seen throgg much sooner
we actually shot a scene for the time
theater in episode 1
of loki getting pummeled by frog thor
but had to cut it to keep things moving
it's too bad because tom was funny as
hell hemsworth will also lend his voice
to thor in the upcoming mcu series what
if
which is set to debut on disney plus on
august 11th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you